[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in [music] this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. As an empowered individual, you do
have options available. who are honored
to continue and share the teachings of
the founding father of science of
[music]
>> [music]
>> The content of this program is to
provide [music] nutritional educa.
Hello everybody, welcome. You'll wait
just a few seconds as people are joining
us here live on Zoom. If you are
watching the live stream and you would
like to join us live on Zoom so that you
can interact with our co-hosts, they are
putting information in the chat here on
Zoom that will help you find information
that we are discussing in our programs.
So join us daily withdoom.com.
So that's all together daily
withdocoom.com.
My name is Becca Dukes and I am so
excited to be the hostess of this
program each and every weekday with the
amazing Dr. Joel Wallik. As a certified
holistic health coach and also on staff
with the Institute of Holistic Health,
it is my honor and privilege to be able
to provide a resource like this so that
we can strengthen our communities. Now,
that's not just here in California where
I'm at. That's not just in the United
States. That's around the world. We have
students that are in Australia, New
Zealand, South Africa, uh, Zimbabwe,
Nigeria, the United Kingdom, Bahrain,
uh, Canada,
Russia, my goodness, the list goes on
and on and on. So, if you have an
interest in health and you would like to
get more information about our certified
holistic health coach course, feel free
to go to coachwithbecka.com.
I do have information there that will
let you know exactly what we do, what
we're about, and how you too can become
a certified holistic health coach with
us. So, welcome everybody to Daily with
Doc
We are here. We're ready. Doc, are you
ready?
>> I'm always ready.
>> Well, then I'm going to introduce you
since you're ready. So, everybody, we
are honored to be
able to gather each and every weekday
with one of the founding fathers of a
science called epigenetics.
Now, epigenetics is a study of how our
genes are expressed.
But it's because of how we eat, how we
live, that those genes are expressed.
I mean, there's there's a lot to it, but
what has gone into Dr. Joel Wallik being
one of the founding fathers of this
science is he started out with a
bachelor of science in agriculture. He
worked in zoos around the world. He
worked on conservation projects around
the world. He even was part of a study
where he was a pathologist
for NASA within the Reese's
um institute. I can't remember the exact
name. Forgive me. I'm human. And that
just proves that anybody can do this. Um
but anyways, he found the cause and the
cure for cystic fibrosis.
And that was just something that
compounded
um his whole journey to be where he is
today. And that is an amazing medical
genius that has dis he's not discovered.
God put it here, but he gave Dr. Wallik
the insight to be able to utilize what
has been provided for the body and
actually let the body thrive instead of
just barely survive. So, Dr. Joel
Wallik, I know that you have an amazing
topic for us because it's something that
people ask about all the time and I
think that there's a lot of
misunderstanding
in regards to this topic. So, tell us
about cholesterol, the good, the bad,
why are they good, why are they bad, or
what's the story? Okay. Well, it all
kind of started out at Eurate Center uh
at Emory University in Atlanta, Georgia.
But that's that's where the epigenetics
thing started. Now, before that, it
actually started when I was nine. I had
a disease that doctors uh thought was um
one of these things where they're going
to put me in jail. It was a it was a a
hospital. It was a It was a prison
hospital is exactly what it was because
I was so violent. Make long story short,
I figured out it was caused by
nutritional deficiencies because I was
eating gluten, couldn't absorb stuff,
wasn't taking supplements, and I began
to eat animal food that had been
supplemented with vitamins and minerals.
And I cured myself in three days,
actually two and a half days. And um for
four years,
20 medical doctors, we're talking about
um pediatricians,
psychologists, pediatric psychologists,
20 of them couldn't figure it out. And I
figured I was only nine years old and I
figured it out myself. And I realized
that doctors really they didn't know
everything. At first, you think, well,
doctors know everything. No, they're way
off.
So, was it like a like a mental
institution or like an insane asylum
that they were wanting to put you in?
>> Put me in an insane asylum, but with
violent criminals.
>> You're just a little kid out of
>> nine years old, but I was very violent
and I was very strong because I throwing
bales of hay on the farm and all that
kind of stuff. They were afraid I was
going to kill somebody. So, they're
going to put me in this this um
um
>> institution.
>> Well, yeah, institution would be a kind
term.
cheer doc or kind.
>> Okay. But anyway,
>> go ahead.
>> But anyway, so it it put me on this path
and um one of the things I learned was
that um doctors don't know everything
and of course my newest book um the wall
revolution. I have to thank you Rebecca
for getting me involved with this. Okay,
because this is the second edition. the
first edition has come came out several
years ago and
>> got it.
>> I'm sorry.
>> I've got it up for you.
>> Oh, okay. Thank you. And um what makes
this particular second version, the
second edition, okay, so valuable. It
has very very famous people
participating in in the chapters and and
the information. We're talking about Pat
Boon. We're talking about Danny Glover.
We're talking about Theo Ratliff,
basketball player. Uh we're talking
about Evander Holyfield,
championship heavyweight boxer. Um and
we're we're talking about all these
people who are involved uh in this
Andy Young, Mayor of Atlanta,
Ambassador, United Nations, and on and
on and on. They're all participating in
this book. Okay? And so they they had
personal benefits from our information
and that's why they contributed to this
book. Okay. And so very very proud of
this and um it's one of those things
where of we we we don't have to make CDs
and DVDs to fit this book because we
already have a hundred of them. Okay,
that actually go along with all of these
stories. Okay, so it's already been
done. Um, and again you can go to
www.drjwwell.com
www.drjwwellik.com
to get the CDs, the DVDs, the books and
so forth. But this book is really
something else. Okay. Now, with that
said, I want to go to it's all in your
head, okay? Go backwards a couple of
years. And it's all in your head um was
a book I had to write because there were
so many incorrect things going around
about diseases in the brain. everything
from cholesterol to um you know eating
too much sugar and all this kind of
stuff and it's one of those things where
there was there was something else going
on and it kind of covered what I had
gone through as a kid and so it was time
for this to come out and um it covers 37
different diseases you get when you get
osteoporosis of skull you get osteopro
your knees doctors do a double knee
replacement you get osteopro your hips
you get a double hip replacement They do
not know there's such a thing as
osteoporosis of the skull. Now, you
might open that up to page six for me if
you would, Becca. And at the top of the
page in page six, okay, in the front
front of the book is have to go a little
bit more to your right. A little bit
more. No, to your There you go. Okay.
You can see that the top skull is the
cranium the top of the skull has been
taken off. You're looking down on the
brain, but the skull is only a quarter
inch thick. Okay. And the bottom one,
they cut the cranium off and you're
looking down on the brain, but the skull
there is an inch and a half to two
inches thick. You can see how that would
be squeezing the tunnels that the 12
pairs of cranial nerves come through and
also
the spinal cord. And so, um, we're going
to talk a little bit about the
cholesterol thing, which has to do with,
uh, sort of along with this, you know,
Alzheimer's disease, MS, gamay syndrome,
Parkinson's disease. Um,
let's see here. Um, Bruce Willis just
had to retire because he can't even
remember his own name. Okay. Because he
has FTD,
frontal temporal dementia. It's kind of
an Alzheimer's disease. It's restricted
to several parts of the brain. It's not
the whole brain like in most Alzheimer's
disease. This is just three parts of the
brain. And then demonization.
Demonization has been known about from
autopsies long before we came up with um
the um the tool okay the tool to look in
a living person and see what's going on
with your mile and the white matter of
the brain which is 100% cholesterol okay
um the okay the tool is the uh MRI
magnetic resonance
okay um imaging very important important
here. You you take an X-ray of the
skull, you just see a big black hole.
But when you use MRI, you get to
actually see the brain and you can see
how it's all shriveled up like a prune
and so forth when you have all these
diseases. That's because people have
followed the doctor's instructions for
over a hundred years. Okay? Because they
made the big mistake. They made the
ultimate mistake. I'll repeat that. They
made the ultimate mistake of over source
of minerals anymore. And doctors said,
"Oh, don't worry about taking vitamins
minerals. Just eat well. You get
everything you need." [snorts] Well,
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blank around the crust of the
earth. They occur in veins like gold and
silver. Okay? In some places, they only
have three minerals. If you're not
supplementing with all 60, you're 57
sharp. You're going to get all these
diseases. Okay? Including, okay,
including what we're talking about
today. Now, when you're talking about
the cholesterol
issue, doctors, you know, we're looking
at clogged arteries. You're saying,
"Okay, the clogging in your arteries is
caused by eating cholesterol. Stop
eating eggs. Stop eating fatty meats. Be
more like a vegetarian and you won't get
plaque in your arteries." Well, that was
nonsense because plaque in your arteries
is caused by eating fried foods,
processed meats with nitrates and
nitrates um and being short in in
minerals. Okay? Because again,
nutritional minerals do not occur in
uniform blanks around the crust of the
earth. They occur in veins like gold and
silver. And we did have bottomland. Some
of you are old enough to remember
bottomland. uh every spring when when
the snow and the ice would melt up in
the mountains, they'd have these big
floods coming down into the valleys and
they would pick up the minerals along
the way, okay? In the soil up in the
mountains and bring it down to the
valleys and and replace the minerals in
the soil in the bottom land were had
been taken out by the plants in the
previous year, by the crops in the
previous year. When they came out with
hydroelectric where they put up the
dams, damned up the rivers and streams
so there was no more flooding, no more
silt to plow back in the salt every
year. Suddenly now we had all these
diseases nobody ever seen before. Okay,
is a mess. Okay, now let's get back to
cholesterol because it's all kind of
related. Cholesterol makes up 25% of
your brain weight, 25% of your spinal
cord weight, makes up 95% of
testosterone weight, 95% of estrogen,
progesterone weight, cholesterol is an
extremely important raw material for
basic tissues and function. Okay? And
doctors said, "Oh, it's a cholesterol."
They came out with drugs like statin
drugs to lower the um cholesterol in
your body. And then people said, "Oh,
just well stop eating eggs and animal
fat and you'll lower cholesterol." And
suddenly now we have all these diseases.
They're cholesterol deficiency diseases.
Okay? So it's absolutely imperative to
eat three eggs twice a day with soft
yolks.
Kids can have one or two scrambled eggs
in butter, okay? Soft scrambled, soft
boiled, soft poached, not fried, okay?
And not hard boiled. Then
um people say, "Oh, they get Alzheimer's
disease. They get all this stuff because
of of cholesterol." No, no, no, no.
Heart attacks are not caused by
cholesterol. Brain stuff is not caused
by cholesterol. It's caused by
cholesterol deficiency. Okay? And so
this is not difficult. And so that's why
we have I26. It says right on the label
provides 25% of your daily requirement
of cholesterol. We have the only product
on the market that has in the label
saying that it gives you a percentage of
the cholesterol you need every day as a
supplement. Okay? That goes along with
your health the brain and heart pack and
your three eggs twice a day with soft
yolks.
And it's imperative. Okay. And when
doctors say, "Oh, your cholesterol is
too high. We got to get you on statin
drugs." Say, "Okay, doctor, you're
fired." And go away and find another
doctor, okay? Because you'll wind up
with Alzheimer's disease. You'll wind up
with MS, multiple scerosis. You'll wind
up with gamb disease, which gam disease
is a multiple scerosis of your spinal
cord. And then there's Parkkins disease,
which is multiple scerosis with tremors.
And then there's the new one, uh, which
is FTD, okay? frontal temporal dementia
which is kind of like a little regional
Alzheimer's disease. Okay. And then um
the dealonization.
Now they only learned a 100 years ago
and before that they could only learn
about demolinization after you died and
they did an autopsy on you because most
people were not going to let a doctor do
a biopsy of your brain. Okay. Okay. But
demonization is a cholesterol
deficiency. And so if you want to have a
great sex life, you know, in addition to
taking your health, brain, and heart
pack, you throw in a guy, you want to
throw in the zera test. Girls, you want
to throw in the zerm. Uh don't forget
your um
let's see here. You also want to throw
in the I26.
And it's one of those things where um
you want to make sure you're taking
everything you need to make sure your
skull is working properly. You don't
have obviously a process of the skull
because uh doctors are going to really
really blame a lot of those symptoms on
cholesterol and take you off of all
cholesterol and put you on
cholesterol-lowering drugs and and
you'll spiral downward and die very
quickly. Okay. So with that said, that's
sort of a summary of what I want to talk
about about cholesterol. Cholesterol is
one of your best friends. If you like
sex, you want cholesterol. If you like
your memory, you want cholesterol. If
you want to be able to function and
perform at your job and get promoted all
the time, you want cholesterol. And so,
again, 75 year track record here
in the in the book uh the Wallock
Revolution. And of course, epigenetics.
Those two books together, I think, are a
good set. Okay, there you go.
Epigenetics. and it's all in your head.
Um, and don't forget that one. And of
course, Rebecca and Dr. Milan and I um
did that. And there's there's a CD that
goes along with it because in a year
after this book came out, we're getting
so much great positive feedback. We did
a CD with more information. So, when we
get when the supply of the book gets
low, we're going to add a lot of this
information, new information to the
book, but we'll keep the CD anyway
because people like to listen to that
CD. So,
and if you want proof about why we're in
trouble, because when we went to
electricity, okay, after 3,000 years of
getting our minerals from wood ashes and
coal ashes, get the book Hell's Kitchen,
just like that bad
um area in New York City where
everything bad happens. Okay, Hell's
Kitchen. These things will tell you
what's going on here. get a hold of that
book. Um, let's see here. Rare Earthbin
Cures. Rare Earthbin Cures. Do you have
a third hand? [laughter]
>> Four or five, doc.
>> Okay. Rare Earthman cures. There you go.
Tells you how to collect hair, where to
ship it, how to read the hair analyses.
Everybody should be getting a hair
analyses once a year. You do not need
permission from a doctor to get a hair
analysis. And you can only learn from a
blood test about your blood levels of
iron. and uh and also calcium. There's
60 essential minerals that you can't
tell much about from a blood sample,
okay? But you can from the hair
analysis. Also, the hair analysis has
another chart in it um which gives you
how many toxic minerals you have and how
much of each toxic mineral you have. You
know, we're talking about lead and
mercury and uranium and so on and so
forth. And these are things if you want
to add these 25 to 50 healthy years of
your life, you got to do this. And then
I'm gonna throw in I think I've got what
two minutes here? Something like that.
>> Something like that.
>> Something like that. What
>> Let me give give me two more minutes.
Okay. And so I want to talk about Jimmy
Carter. He's 98. Um you know, I'm not
into his politics, but he's 98 years old
and and his doctors wanted to put him
into hospice because he's 98 years old.
Not because they had anything wrong with
him, but he's 98 years old. said, "Let's
put you in hospice so we can take care
of you." Something happens. And he says,
"No, thank you. I'll just go home." And
he did. 98 years old. And he's lived on
grits, which is cornmeal, and um eggs,
which you're not supposed to have. He's
lived on um let's see here, seafood,
and vegetables and fruit.
And um he lives on, what they say, corn
and all that kind of stuff. and he only
had peanuts like once a week, not every
day. And he was a peanut guy. And so the
odds are he can live to be 120.
Now he's the oldest living president
ever.
And you know, he told the doctors to
take off when they said that you need to
come in and get into hospice. Well, why?
Well, you're 98 years old. Well, age has
nothing to do with the need to go into
hospice. If you're, you know, dying
because you have 18 different diseases
and you can't breathe and stuff, you
might want to go into hospice. But if
there's nothing wrong with you and
you're paying golf once a week like he
is, okay, and going fishing and hunting
on a regular basis, why would you want
to go into hospice? Well, my doctor
said, okay, so I think I've made my
point. Eat like Jimmy Carter. Take our
90 essential nutrients. Stay away from
all the bad stuff and add 25 to 50
healthy years your life. We want you
around. Over to you, Becca.
>> I'm gonna leave out the peanuts just
because.
>> Yeah, I I don't take them at all. I
don't take them at all.
>> No, nor do I. Well, Dr. Well, like that.
I hope that makes some clarity for
people in regards to cholesterol because
that's one of the very first things that
people come to me with when they have
gone to the doctor, they've gotten some
blood work back and they say, "Well, my
cholesterol is high." My first question
is, "Well, what is high?"
Because I know people that they've been
at 105,
Dr. while on their cholesterol and
they're being put on a statin drug and
105 is very low as it is.
>> Yes.
>> And they're still wanting it to be
lower. And then we wonder why do we have
so many people
that are struggling with brain function.
>> Well, and and that's he's an extreme,
but I'm talking about
it's like an epidemic. Dr. Wallik.
>> Yes. where people they've got brain fog,
they're not able to function, they get
tired easily,
um they their memory.
>> Well, that's because the medical
profession is out misinformation about
cholesterol and insurance pays for the
test. Insurance pays for the medication.
So, people say, "Well, what the heck?
Insurance pays for everything. If it
makes the doctor happy, let the
insurance pay for and I'll do it." Well,
Bruce Willis paid a price. Okay, he's
only 67 years old and he had to retire.
Can't remember his own name. Can't
remember where he lives. I mean, that's
a terrible thing for the diehard
detective.
He was one of my heroes. So, we're
trying to connect with his family and
because I believe we can bring Bruce
Willis back, okay, to being the diehard
Bruce Willis that I knew and loved and
respected.
Well, until you are no longer requiring
oxygen,
there's a lot you can still do, right?
>> You need cholesterol.
>> Yeah, you need cholesterol.
Oh my goodness. Lots of great
information. Thank you so much for
taking the time everybody to join us and
just be a sponge with the information
that's being shared so that whenever the
time comes and you're you're talking to
somebody, you could just squeeze a
little bit of water out and say, "You
know what? I heard this doctor talking
about cholesterol
and I know that there's a recording
somewhere. How would you like to listen
to it?" Well, you can send them to
dailywithdoc.com
and there you will find the recordings
of all of our programs that that we have
done Dr. Wallik since we were doing
askdoc live uh each and every Friday for
two hours way back
>> July of 2020. So two and a half years
ago
>> we were doing that.
So, we have been gathering together and
sharing information for for a few years
now, Dr. Wallik, and it's just getting
better and better and better. I love it.
>> Can't thank you enough.
>> Well, thank you, Dr. Wallik, because if
it wasn't for your research, we wouldn't
have anything to share.
>> Well, right.
>> Well, your team and myself, the whole
group, we make a good team, don't we?
>> Yes, we do. Yes, we do. And I just want
to do a quick little reminder
because they do destroy the lining of
the intestines. Your villi go away. So
you lose that absorptive surface and um
you have to get off those grains. I just
apologize all the farmers because I I
was one. I apologize to the farmers.
They can still grow wheat around oats,
but they have to feed it to animals that
they're only going to feed for three
months and then send them to market.
Okay? Use it as animal feed, not for
human feed. Okay? Wheat run around oats.
And then and no buckwheat because they
have fagopyines, fa pyrenees, which are
worse than gluten. Buckwheat doesn't
have any gluten in it, but it has
faggoyines, which are worse than gluten.
Okay? And so it's one of those things
where you do have to give up the bad
stuff and you have to consciously
proactively supplement. So this guy is
going to give up the bad stuff. No fried
foods, no processed meats, no oils, no
glutens, no wheat, and no butters. When
I say processed meats, we're talking
about bacon and ham and hot dogs and
bologn and salami and pastrami and
pepperoni. Anything with nitrates in it
because that will kill your thyroid
gland. That was my first scientific
publication where 500 died in one night
because the the um temperature
[clears throat] dropped from in the 50s
down to 16 in one night and 500 sheep
just ready to get sheared and go to
market to six month old. They're
perfect, everybody healthy, nothing bad
going on. And all 500 of them died in
the night when the temperature dropped
down to 16 even though they had two
inches of wool and their sheep and and
so forth because they been getting
nitrates in their drinking water from
contamination from fertilizer from the
surrounding farms. I'm a student and I
figured all that out and got it
published. Okay, it was my first
scientific publication and um Marlon
Perkins from the old Mutual Mo Kingdom
show. Okay. And Barry Commoner, the head
of the department of biology at
University of Missouri
um
um or Washington University, excuse me,
Washington University in University
City. Okay. St. Louis um actually um got
a $25 million grant with that article
that I wrote on those sheep and um that
started everything. Of course, my thesis
from that is in the Smithsonian
Institute of National Treasure. They
they um let's see here. Uh that's the
epigenetics book. Okay. The original
book um
sells for $25,000 each. No, very few
people can afford that. Okay. You can
get this one, the epigenetics, for 25
bucks each. Okay. Um it's one of those
things where the information
will add 25 to 50 healthier years to
your life. And so this
um group epigenetics has replaced the
science of genetics. Genetics was a
false theory. Again like like
cholesterol genetics was a false theory.
When doctors didn't know something, they
say, "Oh, it's genetics. It's your body
attacking itself. Oh, it's autoimmune.
Your body's attacking itself." Because
they didn't ever want to say they didn't
know. They were all knowing. they were
medical doctors and so um the
epigenetics changed all that and so I'm
very very proud to be one of the
founding fathers of that science and
it was based on the studies that we did
at Washington University in St. Louis
County. Okay, it was just a big big big
um 10 years 20,000 autopsies
and what should I say it just changed
all of medical science. I'm very proud
of that. Okay. So, I hope that answers
the question.
>> I I think so. So, well, I mean, he's
experiencing gluten. I mean, he's
experiencing bloating and digestive
issues.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. So, basically, he needs to get off
all the gluten. Needs to get off all the
fried foods and, you know, all the bad
stuff. Sugar and carbonated drinks and
oils and all that kind of stuff. Get rid
of all the bad foods. We have the the
book, Dr. Dr. Wik's cooking without the
bad foods. 300 pages of safe recipes and
safe cooking methods. Dr. Wall's cooking
without the bad foods. He needs to get
that book. He needs to get the book
Epigenetics.
Needs to get book the book The Wall
Revolution. Okay. And then um I want him
at you say 200 plus pounds. I want him
to actually get uh our um healthy brain
and heart pack. He can take two of those
per month of photos saying twice a day.
Needs to get two bows a month of our
MSM. So he take three at breakfast at
lunch or dinner time. They're going to
support and promote major repair
cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, disc between a
vertebrae, bone, makes bone itself. And
then [clears throat]
um and because when you have
osteoporosis of the skull, thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Osteoporosis of
the skull squeezing the tense cranial
nerve, the Vegas nerve, you get what's
called gastroparesis. You have belching,
bloing, burping. I mean tremendous uh
stomach pain. It'll bring you to your
knees and doctors think you have an
ulcer, but it's just osteopro to the
skull squeezing that tense cranial
nerve, the vagus nerve. And then let's
see here. Um, he can also take our
ultimate enzymes. Take two of those.
Save five or 10 minutes for each meal. A
couple ounces of water and that should
help with that also. and then give us a
call every couple of weeks and let us
know how it's going because these things
that he has will turn around to normal
within weeks. Within two to six weeks,
it all be normal. If he's on medication
for high blood pressure, don't cold
turkey off of that. But as your blood
pressure drops, you can slowly reduce
medication. If he's got diabetes and
don't cold turkey off that medication,
but as the blood sugar slowly comes to
normal, you can slowly reduce that. But
this is all something we deal with
thousands of times a day all over the
world. We're dealing in 80 countries and
this is a very common scenario.
>> Yes, it is Dr. Wallik. I experienced it
myself years ago.
>> There you go.
>> So, thankfully I have that behind me.
Let's go to Rosemary who we have again
with us today. Rosemary, go ahead and
unmute yourself. You're on live with us.
Try again.
>> There it is. Okay. Well, first off, I
want to thank you for yesterday's
program. It was very, very informative.
>> Thank you.
>> And I really enjoyed it. She talked
about a client or patient of hers who
had a prolapsed
bladder.
>> Yes.
>> About 30 years ago, I was diagnosed with
a prolapsed uterus. Mhm.
>> Are they similar? What's the
>> Yeah. Well, same same cause. You're
missing things that make the tendons and
ligaments do their job, hold
everything's in place.
And um when you have a prolapse, you
have a hernia. This is because you're
missing things that are required to keep
your tendons and ligaments
and connective tissue strong and doing
their jobs. Okay? It's kind of like um
anytime you know you have a a yo-yo and
you leave it go and it'll go down to the
bottom of the string, okay? That's
that's the same as a prolapse.
With a yo-yo, you're supposed to bounce
it back up so it'll wind back up, okay,
and get it again. Okay, but you can't do
that with your uterus. You can't do that
with your bladder. What you have to do
is um actually
get pads and everything to hold
everything in place. What you want to do
is when you sleep at night, put a 4x4
under the feet of the bed. So gravity is
pulling the uterus and the bladder back
into your belly into your pelvis area.
Okay? But you wear that hernia device,
okay? and it'll hold things into place
and that way you won't actually get
things dirty and injured and where you
have to have surgery and get infections
and all kind of stuff. It's the
secondary things that get you when you
have hernas, okay? Those kind of things.
So, you got to pay attention. Usually
people who have those kind of things
have white, gray or silver hair because
the same
nutrients that are missing that cause
hernas and prolapses
>> also cause a loss of hair color.
[cough]
>> Well, this is my natural hair color. I
am blonde.
>> Um I have noticed I I am blonde
>> and this is my natural color. It looks
just like it did 30 years ago.
>> Good.
>> 40 years ago. Um, I did notice when I
got on the 90 that it stopped it from
getting worse. And then I also got on uh
immortalium
and that actually helped it uh quite a
bit.
>> Okay. How old are you now?
>> I'm 77.
>> Okay.
Um,
I run around with pictures in my purse
because people think I'm I'm gayheaded
and I show them what I look like 50
years ago and they say, "Oh, same
color."
So,
but um
it's not painful. It's not deadly. And
so, I've just been living with it.
Doctors want to do a hysterctomy and I
don't.
>> No. Again, you can get pads and with
kind of a a belt and braces and
everything that'll hold things in place
during the day when you're vertical, but
at night, you want to put that 4x4 under
the feet of your bed so gravity helps
you pull everything back into where it
belongs.
>> I'll do that.
>> Is there anything else I can do
nutritionally that would help?
>> Yeah. Yeah, of course. You need things
that are going to be good for your
tendons and ligaments and connective
tissue. Okay. And you weigh how much
again? I weigh 125.
>> Okay. So, I'd have you take u because
you do have a a problem the doctors want
to do surgery on.
I would have you take two healthy brain
and heart packs a month. I weigh 142 and
I do two healthy brain and heart packs a
month. Full dose of twice a day. I also
want you to have two bottles a month of
our MSM. So, you can take three at
breakfast, three at lunch at dinner
time. And they're going to support and
promote maintenance, repair of
cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissues between vertebra,
bone reg, all that kind of stuff,
including all the tendons and ligaments
that hold the uterus and bladder into
place. Okay? They'll make those
ligaments and tendons their normal size
and and length and strength and so
forth. And then um
let's see here. I also want you to take
our collagen peptides. take a um two
canisters of that a month. So you can
take a scuba that your morning drink
with your evening drink.
Okay.
And uh let's go there.
>> Okay. I'm I'm on most of that already.
So I'll
>> again I'm assuming you're done cycling
since you're in your 70s. You don't
cycle anymore.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> Okay. All right. Now, if you want to,
you can also um don't forget the three
eggs twice a day, but you can also
>> Okay. But you can also throw in the
zeraphim.
Um, it'll help your glands make some
estrogen and your estrogen is going to
help you also keep your uterus in the
right place. Okay.
>> Okay.
It's called zera fem
and your body weight. You can go ahead
and take three a day, take one with each
meal, you can take all three at one
meal, whatever you want to do. Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
>> All right. Thank you, Rosemary. Keep
going. Keep going. Love to hear that
you're feeling positive results already.
That is awesome.
Now, Dr. Wallick, in the comments,
there's a question that has to do
because you had mentioned nitrates
>> and they're wanting to know, "How about
the unccured meats that do not have
added nitrates? Are they okay?"
>> Yeah. Oh, you can have like salted meats
um where you have, you know, things
hanging on the the line out there and
they've they've cut meat into strips and
put salt on it and um so forth and it's
just
>> like jerky.
>> Jerky. Yeah, jerky kind of stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay,
>> that's fine. Salt is fine. Salt is
requirement. Of course, we have we like
the the um the salt, okay, that has the
seasoning in it. It's got the 28
minerals in it. This is from Australia
and New Zealand. Okay. Also, once in a
while, we'll get the um salt from the
Himalayan mountains, the Himalayan salt.
Okay? But salt is a required nutrient.
Any doctor would say to you, don't take
salt because it causes blood pressure.
That's absolutely wrong. Sodium is
required for the functioning of every
cell in your body. Chloride is required
in every cell in your body, particularly
in your stomach cells that make
hydrochloric acid. You cannot absorb
minerals. You cannot digest food without
hydrochloric acid. The good Lord gave
us. Okay? The ability to make stomach
acid so we could digest food.
Okay? So staying away from salt, you're
committing a slow, painful, miserable
suicide.
Most definitely.
And then Margaret had mentioned in the
comments here, she said that her son was
sensitive to wheat 36 years ago and they
found that it was even in common
licoricees that are red that are were so
tasty. I mean, they hide
gluten and wheat products, rye, barley,
oats,
>> and so many different things that
sometimes it's just an occurs in those
natural flavorings.
>> So, you want to make sure that you're
really reading labels.
>> Yeah. Well, doctors are giving out
misinformation
that that the salt is bad for you and
gluten is good for you. Okay.
The whole grains are good for you. wheat
brown rat oats, the breakfast of
champions, wedies, Cheerios.
Okay. Um um and then of course there was
the um
spaghetti and bread and pancakes and
waffles. I mean that's why I was so sick
when I was 9 years old. I was eating
waffles and spaghetti and waties and
oatmeal every day. And it's amazing I
didn't die. Okay.
>> Me too. I I was eating it all the time.
[snorts] And then so a topic for the
future, Dr. Wallik, we will be studying
up on the different natural alternative
sweeteners like xylitol and rithrl and
monk fruit. So we've got some questions
in regards to sweeteners. So we're
definitely going to be covering that
also in a future episode of Daily with
Doc.
>> Yeah, we'll put together the
information. Thanks.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And we love questions,
we love comments. So, we want to make
sure that we are providing information
that is
something you're looking for. All right.
You have questions, go to
dailywithdoc.com.
Yes, I got it right. And use that
contact us and send us a message of the
things that you are interested in
knowing about, learning about. If you
have specific health concerns and you
are not already working with a health
coach, you can feel free to use that
contact us. We will make sure that we
get information to you or bring it on
the air as a question so that Dr. Wallik
himself can use your question to teach
others around the world for many many
many years. Dr. Wallik, I love how we
can do one recording and it can be
shared a million times and watched a
million more.
>> Well, this is a blessing to have this
have this talent that you and your team
has to put together these tools that we
can they'll be around for a thousand
years after we're gone. And I'm just
very excited about that. And and so we
do have other projects that are coming.
It's going to blow people's minds. Okay,
the the projects we have coming out here
pretty quickly, they're they're near
done. And I'm I'm so excited about this.
And the whole idea is to build this
inventory, this this library, if you
will. And of course, my thesis that I
did that sells for $25,000 each, that
big $25 million project at Washington
University in St. Louis,
um that's in the Smithsonian Institute
as a national treasure.
Does your doctor have a a thesis in the
Smithsonian Institute as a National
Treasure? Now, I'm not I'm not trying to
brag, but I'm just saying somebody
thought my my research was of some
value. They put it in the Smithsonian
Institute as a as a national treasure.
And I'm in the process of finding out
how many people have a thesis in the
Smithsonian Institute's national
treasure. I'm particularly looking for
how many medical people, you know, how
many doctors, how many nurses, how many
pharmacists, uh, and you might help me
with that because you're very good at
that sort of stuff, Rebecca. Let's find
out how many people
>> h
>> have a do use a computer. Um, okay. And
and it's one of those things where how
many people have their thesis in the
Smithsonian Institute's National
Treasure. I guarantee it's not a lot.
Okay. And so I'm very very proud of
that. But it just tells you that all the
things we're talking about are
important. You don't get put into the
Smithsonian Institute as a national
treasure if what you're saying is
frivolous.
>> It's true. They they do do a little bit
of um factchecking, Dr. Wallik.
>> Yeah,
>> just a maybe [laughter] a little bit.
So we have another question, Dr. Wallik.
And I think Marilyn has her hand up to
ask it for us. Marilyn,
>> yes. Um, they're in the chat. Uh, and
Irene asked a question. She's a female,
70 years old, 140 pounds, and she wants
to know why she has to run to the
bathroom every half an hour. She drinks
a lot of water to be hydrated.
>> Okay, that's very easy. Um, do you know
if she has any ringing in the ears or
any balance problems?
>> Um, she doesn't mention anything else. I
don't know if she
>> We have to ask her these questions.
>> Let's see if we can get Irene to come on
with us.
Irene,
can you go ahead and unmute yourself?
>> Yes, I'm here.
>> Okay, Irene, uh, thank you for coming
on. Do you have any ringing in your
ears? any tenitis or ringing or roaring
or buzzing in your ears?
>> Buzzing's like a seashell.
>> Okay. Like like listening to a seashell.
Okay. And then um do you ever let's see
here. Um do you also um
and you wake up at night to to urinate
three, four, five, eight, 10 times?
>> Uh at least three times.
>> At least three times. Yeah.
>> Okay. Then do you have any balance
problems? Any vertigo? Any dizziness? Do
you need a walker or a cane or anything
like that?
>> No.
>> Okay. Do you have any trouble
swallowing? Do you have have your voice
changed? Anything like that?
>> No.
>> Okay. Do you have an irregular heartbeat
or a slow heart rate or a fast heart
rate?
>> No.
>> Okay, good. Well, you have osteoporosis
of the skull.
>> Okay. The osteoporosis of the skull is
squeezing your spinal cord. That's why
you're having these issues with um
polyurea, okay? Because your your skull
is squeezing your spinal cord. The
spinal cord is telling your urinary
bladder to urinate. I know you don't
have a prostate problem because you're a
girl. Girls don't have prostate glands.
Now, if you're a boy, the first thing
that the medical doctors want to do, oh,
we got to do a biopsy to see if you have
prostate cancer and blah blah blah blah
blah. But they got to bite their fingers
when this happens to a lady because you
don't have a prostate gland.
Okay. But the skull is squeezing the
spinal cord because the skull is made in
the brain. Comes out of the back of the
skull. And this is where you need to get
a hold. You'll understand this. You get
a hold of the book and the CD that that
there you go. That Rebecca and Dr. Milan
and I have done. Okay? It's all in your
head. And it goes into 37 different
diseases,
17 of which occur from the skull down
the spinal cord. Okay? Now when you get
osteoporosis of your knees, you get a
double knee replacement. When you get
osteoporosis of your hips, you get a
double hip replacement. You get
osteoporosis of the skull, can they give
you a double head replacement? Of course
not. So doctors don't want to talk about
osteoporosis of the skull even if they
know about it. But I don't think they
teach that in school to medical school.
I'm the guy that discovered this. And
this book is one of our bestsellers
here. It just sells like crazy because
people say, "Well, that's me. That's me.
That's me." And the doctor just says,
"I'm getting old. I got to get used to
it." No, it's because you have
osteoporosis of the skull squeezing
those nerves and squeezing the spinal
cord and it all goes away very quickly
when you take the healthy brain and
heart pack. You take the MSM, you take
the collagen peptides, you take the
vitamin D3, don't forget the synaptive,
take three of those twice a day so your
brain cells can talk to each other.
Don't forget your I 26 so your brain
cells can talk to each other, okay? and
with memory and all that kind of stuff
and you know what they need to do in
proper uh form and so the I26 you I take
three of those a day on breakfast lunch
when dinner sometimes I'll just take all
three at lunchtime along with some
cheese sticks
and taste good you know they're not much
they don't taste like candy but they're
pleasant okay they're about the diameter
of a quarter or chewables they're only a
millimeter thick but they're the di flat
diameter like a disc, okay? Like a
quarter. [clears throat] And they're
chewable and and they're pleasant
tasting. I'll just say they're pleasant
tasting, okay? I don't get the big kick
out of the taste, but they're they're
pleasant. They don't taste bad. They're
not bitter. They're not yucky. Okay? And
so, um, this is something that you will
be able to very quickly resolve your
problems.
>> All right. Thank you so much, Irene, for
coming on and letting Doc ask you a few
more questions because it's those
symptoms.
You'll notice that Dr. Wallick is asking
symptoms about different parts of the
body.
And when you think about it, it just
totally makes sense because you've got
the vagus nerve that comes here out of
the brain, goes down the spinal cord.
You've got all the little branches that
are going to every single part of the
brain, I mean the body. So if
something's happening up here in the
brain, how can it not affect things down
lower? You'd call it downstream, Dr.
Wallik.
>> Yes, that's downstream stuff.
>> So [clears throat] it totally makes
sense. This is something that I was
dealing with. And as I was going through
all these different conditions that are
listed here on the book, I'm like, um,
no, no, yes, no. You know, all the
different things that I could say yes
to. And then as time progressed, we
found more and more things that had
these symptoms. Dr. Wallik did. And I'm
like, "Okay, we've got the books. We
can't just put it in the book. Let's do
a CD." And added the CD to the book that
has more. So, with the next edition of
It's All in Your Head, there will be
additional that are added on there. And
that just means we have to do another
CD. Dr. Well, like I know somebody that
knows how to do that and [clears throat]
and I think she works pretty cheap. So,
there we go. It's all about getting the
information into the hands of people
that it can help folks and that's what
this program is all about. Dr. Wallik, I
know that our time with you is here
running short. We just thank you so much
again for another 50 minutes of
information that we can utilize and not
just survive but actually thrive. So
thank you Dr. Wallik. I appreciate you
so much.
>> Well we are family. Thank you and your
team and thank you all of our followers
and listeners, all of our longevity
people because the world needs you. The
world needs you. um this information
must get out there and that's why we're
doing as many books and CDs and videos
and all the things we can do and and of
course this program um let's see here
daily with Doc five days a week. Holy
moly, this is very good stuff. Thank you
so much.
>> And we're live with video and we are
being broad uh live streamed broadcasted
on many different platforms. So folks,
make sure that you're following us on
YouTube. Dr. Rolick, I'm going to go
ahead and let you go so you can get to
your next program.
>> But make sure that you're following us
on YouTube and Rumble and Oops. I did
the wrong one.
Hold on. Hold on. I'm getting rid of
you.
He's making fun of me now, folks. There
we go. Thank you so much. And if I could
get my co-hosts who were helping me out
on that one to come on stream with me, I
just want to give them a great big shout
out and thank you because without them I
would not be able to do this. There are
so many different moving parts here.
We've got our
our executive of production that makes
sure that all the streams are working.
We have Marilyn who is part of a
production team here who makes sure that
people are getting information in the
chat and who's not with us. We have
Jonty. He is our technical advisor who
is just the master when it comes to
websites and all things production. So,
SunPowered Productions, if you're ever
looking for a production company to help
you with your digital marketing,
is my number one recommendation.
So, on behalf of the Daily with Doc
Show,
my name is Rebecca Dukes and we invite
you to get back with the person that
shared this program with you. If there
is nobody to thank, go ahead and go to
dailywithdoc.com
and there we have all of our replays. We
have the 10 good foods bad foods list
because I know Dr. Wallet goes through
it really fast. Sometimes we need
something to print out so we can put it
on the refrigerator or you can even
download and save it so that it's on
your phone anytime you go to the store.
You have that available. And if you have
questions or you'd like to get started
working with a certified holistic health
coach, use that contact us and you will
get information and that will connect
you with somebody that can best fit you
where you're at. Because we don't just
pile things on to pile things on, folks.
You as an individual are an individual
with individual needs and we make sure
that you're getting what you need to get
the best optimal results. So until
tomorrow, bye for now.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
Heat.
Heat. [music]
>> [music]
>> Heat.
Heat.
[music]